si dans l'émission d'hier rené
malleville a annoncé avec émotion son
départ définitif de tpm p c'est en
partie en raison des rires de benjamin
castaldi et jean michel maire qu'il a
considérés comme malveillants
si benjamin castaldi s'est excusé hier
soir en direct en affirmant ne vouloir
faire aucun mal à rené à aucun moment
j'ai voulu me tuer les nids te rabaisser
j'ai voulu rigoler on aimerait
j'aimerais bien pas seulement tu restes
certains internautes s'en sont
directement pris à lui j'espère que
benjamin castaldi sera sanctionnée de la
perte de rené dans l'émission sur les
réseaux des corses n'ont pas hésité à
insulter voire menacer de mort rage en
main castaldi des menaces envers sa
famille également qui sont intolérables
aux menaces ne tuer ma famille de
monsieur mes enfants de déterrer ma mère
ma grand mère parce que j'ai ri on va
menacer de mort et là je suis pas
d'accord aujourd'hui un hashtag boycott
castaldi est apparue sur twitter un
acharnement et une violence qui ont
poussé l'animateur a quitté
temporairement les réseaux alors menaces
insultes
benjamin castaldi at il bien fait de
quitter les réseaux sociaux
en belgique est avec nous ce soir et
avant que benji pris la parole je veux
dire que benjamin c'est un des mecs les
plus cool que je connaisse dans le
métier et je peux vous dire c'est un mec
qui n'a pas une once de méchanceté et
vraiment ça m'a fait énormément d'argent
non mais c'est vraiment c'est certain
que ça m'a fait beaucoup de peine pour
benji qui s'est juste marrer avec moi
non mais la vérité voilà et on vous fait
pas il s'est pas moqué de rené benjamin
juste on a été pris d'un fou rire comme
des gamins en classe parce que rené il
faut avouer
rené est très drôle voilà c'est vrai on
a tout mettez tous en fourrure même
géraldine maillet parce que rené quand
il nous a sorti sa feuille et qu'il a lu
le professeur tartare et le spi folle
j'ai eu des milliers de sms de potes
derrière qui m'ont dit est ce que toi tu
fais partie du spip est ce que gilles
bernès les parties du spi ça a été un
déferlement dans un rack ball et toute
la soirée
voilà donc là vraiment il n'y a pas eu
c'est pas un truc méchant contre rené on
n'y a personne a été méchant couronné en
plus heureux des salles et il était
vraiment accueilli comme un roi ici la
belle a envoyé il est temps l'objectif
est celui qui venait le plus tôt et on
était du temps avec meriem et tuer c'est
vrai que benji ça a été je vous le dis
ce qu'il a vécu sur les réseaux sociaux
va nous rapporter benjamin c'était très
très dur et pour sa famille ça a été
très dur à côté nous les les tweets à
n'est plus faux dur nous avait reçus gc
c'est ce que j'ai vu sur les réseaux
sociaux
c'est au delà de ce qu'on peut imaginer
faire que pour pop art à parce que jerry
nos abrutis et crétin menaces web comme
nation j'ai 25 ans de métier franchement
j'en ai vu des vertes et des pas mûres
jeunes ans j'en ai rien à car il peut
bien ils peuvent dire ce qu'ils veulent
que je vous suce la voilà ce que vous
voulez que ces progrès ont eu en plus
sur vous c'est même pas vrai je suis
votre clébard que je suis un gars que je
suis un admin tout ça mais faites vous
plaisir c'est mon métier c'est pas trop
m après et c'est et à remettre en fait
ça s'est détournée petit à petit la voie
des musées témoin après fouille valax et
sainement et en plus ya noté il y avait
des commentaires qui étaient
intelligents et qu'ils utilisent et la
vérité benji cyril jean michel vous avez
été pas trop loin vous avez ça trop duré
calmez vous voilà c'était ça et parce
que j'ai eu un fou rire parce que je
suis là pour amuser les gens et pour
rire je me fais chier dessus ça c'est
pas très grave mais ma famille mes
enfants et giulia une chose on parle de
l'âge de rooney effectivement il ya 113
ans moi j'ai julien et simon ils ont une
grand mère qu'est pas dans le métier
qu'à 76 ans qui abonnés à 2 contre
elle a à la pelle en art mal d'aimer
jules-simon son beau fils inc
mais qu'est ce qui se passe on veut tuer
mes petits-enfants non mais vous rendez
compte
et ça c'est pas tolérés qu'est ce qu'on
vous a dit sur les ondes à dire on va et
ventre et on tombe du dernier mandat
aussi faut il faut savoir que ses pulls
harcèlement c'est pas possible
moi j'en ai rien à [ __ ] qu'on parle
qu'on parle mal de moi mais con qu'on
touche mes enfants ça me fait de la
peine ma femme allaiter alors allez
envoyer un message à stan était en
colère à la pas aimé le côté tribunal
populaire voilà moi je me suis dis
franchement je me suis excusé auprès
d'andré mais pourquoi parce que j'ai
rigolé on en est là aujourd'hui il faut
s'excuser parce qu'on rigole c'est pas
c'est pas une blague dans ce pays je me
suis marré avec un mec est un et je vais
m'excuser d'avoir ri nom et prénom mais
à 30
après on fera quoi sert il nous nous on
est dans quel monde non mais chine je
suis je peux plus supporter ça alors moi
je le sais d'accord avec vous c'est vrai
qu'à paris mais ça va rené était bon on
a pas il n'a pas insulté moi je l'aimé
pas insulter l'avenir du temps où la
doré en plus c'est un mec il me fait
rire c'est un personnage haut en couleur
un personnage alors je vous le dis je
vous le dis je sais pas si c'est son
comité manageo s'est il fait un tweet
qui met le feu aux poudres où il est il
a un discours qui est agressif qui est
normal il est blessé mais ce clip tu as
une wii dit que y'a que ses deux
petits-enfants son inexpérience a
déclenché des horreurs réfléchissez les
mecs avant tout était pensé aux
conséquences penser que moi j'ai des
enfants que gbg il ya des grands mères
j'ai une robe lamée grand mère de mes
enfants allez allez mais traumatisée
elle est abonnée 2 contre alain julien
simon à l'appel elle était en larmes
mais qu'est-ce qui se passe j'ai mon
rôle est la grand-mère de dégâts réels
et marseille mais je me suis marié à
marseille c'est que jean paul bodin qui
met qu'imam en plus en plus ses veines
fait de 2,2 de combat à la con entre
paris et marseille qui ne veut rien dire
c'est débile
vous êtes des build pense à tous et
n'importe quoi et on est arrivé à un
point alors moi je vais te manger des
bonbons chez twitter parce que je ne
vais pas non plus me faire chier dessus
du matin au soir
mais c'est même pas les insultes alors
je vous passe tu es un nul terrain c'est
pas grave
et puis c'est monter ses montées ses
montées c'est monté alors les menaces de
main pour l'instant je vais pas porter
plainte pas que je vais pas encombrer là
je pense que l'habitat ush à [ __ ] en
ce moment de penser que c'est trop tôt
en revanche si ça continue sur ma
famille sur mes enfants sur surtout ce
type portent le nom de castaldi au bout
d'un an ça je dirais non parce que ça
commence vraiment c'est extrêmement
besson moi je m'en fous mais au bout
d'un moment arrêter quoi ça suffit alors
voilà s'il me scie gdc rhône et j'en
suis désolé je me suis que les mille
fois
je vais pas non plus me mettre à quatre
pattes parce que j'ai rigolé dans une
émission de télévision souhaite que veut
dire ça va c'est une émission de
divertissement plus on est là pour
rigoler ça c'est ont fêté pmp suis
désolé faut avoir un peu le cul le le le
cuir un peu dur
on en apprend tous font la gueule c'est
le principe et ben si c'est trop dur
faut pas faire de télé voilà d'accord
voilà chez c'est toucher j'irai pas plus
loin là dessus mais moi voilà je suis je
suis en plus d'allergies mais j'ai
remarqué un truc à croire que ceux qui
sont sur twitter sont vraiment haineux
et ils n'ont pas de gameplay et ce sur
install sont plus polis j'ai eu des tas
de messages d'un stade lors qu'ils m'ont
dit c'était pas drôle vous n'avez pas
été respectueux et il avait raison mais
c'était écrit avec des mots français
sans fautes d'orthographes et poliment
voyez ce que je veux dire je vais pas
nicolas maire ni ta grand mère c'était
moi c'est on est dans un on est aux jeux
vous et moi je comprends pas qu'on parle
souvent du harcèlement etc
moi je pense à tous les mômes qui sont
ces s'il n'y a pas que les gens vous
connus qui sont harcelés ya tout le
monde qui se fait harceler et ça prend
des proportions délirantes
hier j'ai envoyé un total elo je dois
aller à mars et dans ma famille le
week-end prochain mais franchement j'ai
peur d'aller à marseille
alors voilà mais je vous dis tous les
marseillais ou et essai et incontrôlée
marseillais mais non mais en plus oui
mais oui j'ai un club de foot à
marseille s'est aisément comprendre la
chose est encore une fois moi j'ai une
famille j'ai des enfants j'ai rien
contre
ggd granger il ya des grands mères il ya
des grands parents qui comprennent rien
à tout ça je vous dis ça a des
conséquences et la grand-mère du lait
brême qui appelle ce matin denis mais
qu'est ce qui se passe bien de mekhatria
que c'est votre petit dernier oui/non
mais allait s'en prendre à un bébé de
deux mois et demi non mais des mecs et
médard faut redescendre de minutes
c'est serré c'est fou c'est fou ça alors
moi je vois l'ajout d'une chose et que
ça me fait réfléchir mais ça fait un
moment dans l'appareil sert il depuis un
moment on sait que son rebond a noté il
faut faire attention à ce qu'on dit
parce qu'elle est conséquent serait ce
qu'un coup ci et là vous n'avez rien
fait mais là dans ce cas précis mais
arrêtez voilà on va pas non plus
s'excuser sans cesse de tout en
permanence parce qu'il ya trois connards
qui vous menace de mort sur ceux sur les
réseaux je comprenais et puis et puis là
il y avait vraiment rien gap n'y a rien
eu de rire venez il était heureusement
nabab ici il a passé des moments
exceptionnels
après rené jeudi j'adore rené rené les
chérit le seul truc qu'il a il faut pas
oublier la 73 ans les chéris il n'a pas
le même humour que nous il peut
comprendre il peut croire que voilà on
peut se moquer de lui on se moque de
tout le monde ici voilà et insulte quand
même mieux avec du recul rooney va dire
c'est pas très grave et benjamins il a
juste rigolé parce que rené et drool
rené c'est un sketch à lui tout seul et
bien sûr
il est exceptionnel et moi j'adore les
accents j'adore et je pense qu'il n'a
pas été défense qu'on l'à beaucoup
remonté rhône et beaucoup lui parler ce
qui m'a quand même reparlé de la sphère
de sa tante
on n'a jamais ri du fait que sa tante
était tombé du ravin jamais de la vie on
arrive à tous son histoire était très
drôle mais il est il en a reparlé donc
on sait pas alors effectivement il a
effectivement eu des premiers degrés à
100% mais je pense qu'il s'est fait
monter comme on dirait le bourrichon
voilà je pense qu'on lui a parlé
beaucoup ont dicté quoi tu vas là-bas on
te respecte pa té un marseillais était
un fierté un machin tu t'écrases comme
une carpette
mais on ne sait jamais habana pas assez
crade et parce qu'à aucune ne l'est pas
toujours méchant ici jamais bon effectué
rigoler et jamais on n'a jamais habité
rhône et pour [ __ ] de sa gueule on
agit on n'a jamais ri a cédé bandas ont
pensé rire avec lui et je pense il a pas
compris ça et au ici il n'y a pas une
personne sur ce plateau qu'on n'a pas
pris plein la figure
magali berda avons fait les démissions
de vendée ensemble je lâche arrive aussi
sur les voies la mamie c'est en
permanence guinea en permanence alors n
ont pas daniel moreau on n'arrête pas de
on arrive à des crises avait dû si
j'avais dû quitter l'émission parce
qu'on va charrier ou mais je serai plus
là depuis le pour régir attaque aux
téléspectateurs un peu cette année et
j'en parlais que delphine wespiser
encore hier qu'il est revenu
elle m'a dit j'ai jamais vu une telle
ambiance cette année une telle bonne
ambiance dans l'émission touche pas à
mon pote vraiment je pense qu'on n'a
jamais eu une aussi bonne ambiance dans
l'émission tout le monde s'en est main
de fer dont on rigole comme des fous
voilà dans les couloirs moi je vois là
dès que je les vois on fait que déconner
tout se passe bien on a au poids là on a
on n'a pas de soucis cette année on
kiffe
on pense qu'à vous faire kiffer parce
que c'est des périodes difficiles et
rené on était hyper content de le voir
un jour et benjamins jouent jeudi n'a
pas pensé une seconde loi faire du mal
géré et aujourd'hui ce qui arrive à
benjamin sur les réseaux jégo je vous le
dis c'est inadmissible c'est terrible un
guillaume
moi je veux dire cette affaire elle
montre un vrai problème aujourd'hui
c'est que n'importe qui peut menacer
quelqu'un de mort gratuitement et
anonymement
benjamin tu parlais tout à l'heure de
porter plainte que tu réfléchissait à
peut-être porté plainte pour ceux qui
insultent la famille mais je vais dire
ce qui va se passer si tu portes plainte
il va rien se passer parce que le
problème en france c'est que vous pouvez
recevoir des menaces de mort vous pouvez
menacer quelqu'un moi j'ai été menacée
de mort pendant deux ans par quelqu'un
qui m'appelait tous les jours qui
menaçait violemment qui écrit qui a
écrit des saloperies sur sur moi sur
internet etc
j'ai porté plainte trois fois il ne
s'est rien passé donc je ne jette pas la
pierre aux policiers qui ont
effectivement autre chose à faire mais
c'est quand même extrêmement grave
demeure
c'est quelqu'un dehors parce que
peut-être que benjamin en a rien à faire
mais au fond de toi c'est jamais
agréable d'avoir quelqu'un je vais tuer
je peux pas prendre au sérieux parce que
j'espère que vous avez reçus parce qu'un
péché par envoi ou alors le pire c'est
horrible et vont et montrer le petit
dernier on va butter dans la famille où
habitait ta femme au but but but et
c'était quoi les messages
on va on va [ __ ] ta famille on va
débuter mais c'est ça on va te faire là
pour connard c'est aussi court que ça
est-ce que vous avez rigolé mais il va
suggérer mollet mais parce que ça a pris
ça après tout un truc c'est ce qui est
je vous dis c'est absolument délirant
bien concède fait peur il faut pas que
j'ai peur je vais pas non plus avoir
peur de chanter dans la rue parce que
encore une fois on fait les mots est
facile de faire un message derrière son
mot souffrance état pas très bien facile
mais c'est vrai que tout moi je dois
aller à marseille le week-end prochain
ils sont formidables mais bon moi je
sais pas je sais rien mais pourquoi
j'espère très intelligente et résultat
c'est qu'on on adore rené et on
rassemble les adore et les marseillais
et non mais leur refuse une plainte
parce qu'il ya deux il ya deux il ya
deux mecs de marseille et puis je vous
dire les marseillais on est très
regardée à marseille on adore marseille
bien sûr qu'on sait même faire la seule
délocalisations que devait faire cette à
marseille un moment avec le film taxi
saint max essey voilà et c'est vrai
qu'on adore on adore les marseillais là
ça n'a rien à voir avec rené c'est pas
que ces sanctions étaient un lillois on
aurait pas une espèce de truc qui est
montée comme ça mais c'est très sérieux
ce n'est pas un message ces passants
message ça ne va pas on parle de 2 3 me
le message est roi mais c'est charlie
c'est du délire c'est ma bulle n'a
jamais reçu de 3000 messages à
l'interprète de regarder parce qu'au
bout d'un moment c'est fini et je dis
merci a bientot terminer sur facebook
aussi j'ai vu que c'était un vieux pote
et moi je n'ai même pas ouvrir le
facebook sar ousa qu'est ce que vous a
dit votre femme allaitant elle était en
colère à l'été en aller a été en colère
elle nul à l'image à moi tu fais pas ce
métier pour ça pour vivre ça a été un
animateur qu'à un creux d'un vallon si
vous n'avez rien c'est ne meurent plus
avoué c'est ça et me dit mais à le
maniement donc on en est là maintenant
on en arrive là parce que tu as au terme
d un fou rire samba ba moi je vais vous
dire la vérité quand je vois ça il ya
des gens qui disent des choses à la
télévision surtout en ce moment horrible
vraiment horrible est inadmissible
nous dans touche pas à mon poste cette
semaine je parle j'ai pas envie de faire
ça mais voilà nous on a une idée on aide
monde et l'émission je pense qu'ils
aident le plus de gens possible parce
qu'on a envie de le faire parce qu'on
est dans une émission bienveillante
qu'on a envie de rigoler qu'on est là
pour rigoler pour aider les gens pour
vous changer les idées et ont des
missions je pense qu'il fait le plus
pour les autres et d'ailleurs à chaque
fois qu'une personne
en difficulté et qui a des soucis elle
essaie de nous contacter ou de me
contacter ou de venir devant le studio
et on essaie de faire le nécessaire
juste là benjamin ce qu'il a fait c'est
pas grave alors qu'il ya des mecs qui
sortent des choses dans des émissions d
horreur des horreurs
oui voilà et il a juste un truc c'est
que nous on est une émission je vous le
dis on est vraiment ses comptes dire ça
ou on n'est qu'amour rené hier on est en
train de boire des coups avec lui tout
va bien il n'y a aucune guerre on les
aime moi j'espère juste une chose c'est
que rené change d'avis et qui reviennent
nous voir et je désespère pas que je
suis sûr qu'il va changer d'avis rodez
et nous juste on est là pour vous
divertir
on est une bande de potes on s'est marré
sur le truc parce que vraiment c'était
très drôle
il n'y avait pas mort d'homme vraiment
cc oui je skate et rich les quelques
milliers qui ont trouvé qu'on a été trop
loin alors d'achat si on était tous là
on le savait pas si on avait vu que ça
commence à le choc et on se sera arrêtée
vers la cuy quillan rigoler avec nous
après l'émission c'est moi je suis
partie en nylon bisous le cigem poursuit
il avait choqué jamais je ne serai
permet de dire ça mais le problème c'est
que les quelques milliers voilà qui ont
été choqués parce qu'on est trop loin il
étouffe complètement les centaines de
milliers qui rigolaient en même temps tu
nous tiens voilà cinq ans et que
certains téléspectateurs et bien j'ai eu
des barbares et on n'entend que ce qui
était jeudi c'est un épiphénomène au
swing et pu fédérer quand tu lis de 3000
messages si rien du tout alors je sais
que ça peut faire beaucoup mais c'est
rien après après les voilà moi je me
suis énervé je me suis énervé parce que
moi je m'en fous encore une fois je m'en
fous je ne le porte pas attention je
vous le dis quand ça remonte aux grands
parents à mes enfants qui sont pas bien
que ce terme mon fils et la fille a fait
une story pendant 20 minutes pour
expliquer à la des choses qui sait plus
quoi faire au montant du bail il a une
fois votre fils y regarder on l'a
insultée pauv'con à ton père un [ __ ]
on va débuter mais ça n'a pas de sens où
aller ni mais que ça n'a pas de sens et
là pas de sens
enzo a été emmerdé ya les îles où son
truc ça il y avait plein de messages
simon pareil julien pareil ils bossent
avec magali d'ailleurs cessé à l'origine
est un peu plus grands il ya vingt
quatre ans il n'a pas à la peau un peu
plus dur m'a fallu aider les petits à
tous les gens qui s'appellent castadère
mon frère gay j'en ai sportif
ben oui un film à nagl il a vu plein la
gueule il a rien demandé mon frère
foutez lui la paix remonterait re ok ben
voilà
sauf que ça passait pas possible donc la
scène aménagée pas la partie corrigé
juste un truc à dire bien évidemment
jean tour tout ce que dit benjamin mais
vous qui me détendre combats arrêtés pmp
ouvert à tous et l'autre est ce qu'on
peut pas mener un combat pour qu'ils
aient une juste
des réseaux sociaux c'est à dire juste
ni masqueront par le benjamin la méouge
tout n'est qu'hier on avait une artiste
qui a été harcelé parce qu'elle avait
fait beau ce qu'ils étaient obligés de
déménager avec vous en souvenez que ça
est ce qu'aujourd'hui on peut pas
essayer de mener quelque chose pour
qu'ils aient une espèce de justice des
réseaux sociaux parce que se faire
insulter c'est toujours pareil vous fait
insulter en fait par 100 personnes qui
se sont des faux comptes à la plupart du
temps mais on peut remonter à ces gens
moi j'ai porté plainte une fois je ne
dirais pas contre qui puisque j'ai su
qu'ils s'étaient quand j'étais à france
télévisions j'ai été menacé par par
quelqu'un j'ai porté plainte ça a duré
quatre mois
ils ont fait une enquête donc il faut il
faut pas dire qu'on mène pas forcément
l'anc est là c'est qu'ils ont peut-être
pas forcément le temps mais je pense que
le problème des réseaux sociaux ça doit
être un combat national
est-ce qu'on peut pas le mener ensemble
ce combat sur vous avez raison monsieur
mono qui paie je vais essayer de voir ce
que je peux faire
benjamin je voulais juste te dire mon
chéri que je suis très peiné pour toi
pour ta famille tu sais que je t'aime
mon chéri tu sais que ça va se tasser un
jeu c'est un boni de gaza reste que la
télé mais c'est n'a rien fait de mal
n'oublions rien fait de mal voilà que et
rené bien sûr ou l'aiment et rené en
extérieur qui va revenir nous voir
voilà et ça se passe très bien qu on est
en train de boire des coups hier donc il
n'y a aucune guerre rien du tout voilà
en tout cas mais elle veut un couvent où
ben j aurais même mois non a fait boire
du pastis